масштабні терористичні атаки Росії на
українській мові міста спричинили
масовий перехід на онлайн уроки у школах
до кінця тижня навчатимуться дистанційно
учнів у Чернігові після цього підуть на
канікули у Житомирі сьогодні навчальні
заклади не працювали через відсутність
електрики проте як ворожі атаки
впливають на освітній процес в Україні
поговоримо вже зараз з нашим
співрозмовником до ефіру долучається
Сергій шкарлет Міністр освіти і науки
України розпитаємо про виклики для
освіти у воєнний час нижче про безпеку
та психологічний стан дітей п міністра
Вітаю вас вітаю вас Доброго вечора
Доброго вечора і ще тиждень тому ви
говорили що про заборону очного навчання
поки що не йдеться Ну але після чергових
російських атак чи не змінилася позиція
хто прийматиме рішення про форму
навчання в тій чи іншій школі тепер
Добрий вечір перш за все хочу подякувати
за
активну зацікавленість у висвітленій
події щодо освіти це дуже важливо на
сьогодні хочу нагадати що в кожному
конкретному випадку рішення приймає все
ж таки засновник Це військова
адміністрація або органи місцевого
самоврядування але перш за все
наголошував наголошую що перш за все є
питання безпеки
на сьогодні ми очікуємо інформацію щодо
70% шкіл які в принципі готові до
запровадження очного навчання але
сьогодні перш за все ми чітко розуміємо
що є батьки які
мають побоювання щодо відправлення або
направлення своїх дітей до школи є інші
категорії батьків які теж вважають це не
поодинокі випадки коли батьки вважають
що все ж таки в школі буде безпечніше
адже дитина яка сама знаходиться на
поверхах на сьомому на дев'ятому поверху
вдома сама це можливо більш небезпечно
ніж коли вчитель або навчений працівник
зможе при повітряної тривоги евакуювати
дитину до безпечного місця до
найпростішого наприклад укриття як
малювати
Як завжди Це Це питання постійно
непокоїть як війна впливає на якість
освіти в Україні чи проводяться зараз
зрізи знань і Якщо так то що вони
демонструють психічний стан дітей також
суттєво впливає на якісь засвоєння нової
інформації чи змінилися підходи Ну до
Скажімо так психологічної оцінки стану
дітей ви знаєте починаючи з перших днів
війни навіть з першого дня війни я
звернувся до 9 департаментів освіти до
керівників закладів освіти в яких є
кафедри психології соціології
для того щоб в перші дні війни
забезпечити максимальну психологічну
підтримку навіть на найпростішому рівні
і наших переселенців І тих дітей тих
вчителів тих батьків які попали під
вороже обстріли вимушені були
евакуюватись звісно психологічна
підтримка цієї на першому місці сьогодні
взагалі в освітньому процесі при чому
тільки для учнів а й для
вчителів і ми на сьогодні запроваджуємо
цілий ряд під патронатом першої леді
України пані олені Зеленського Ми
запроваджуємо цілий ряд проектів щодо
психологічного навчання психологічної
підтримки психологічного реакції
педагогів на поведінку дітей на
виявлення певних ознак психологічного
розладу і в цьому контексті ми плануємо
що майже 600 тисяч освітян коли йде таку
попередню як підготовку щодо первинних
ознак психологічної підготовки і праці в
освітніх колективах звісно якістю освіти
якість онлайн освіти якість взагалі
перервної освіти впливає на взагалі на
компетенцію і на компетентності учасники
освітнього процесу саме тому починаючи з
десятого дня початку повномасштабної
агресії ми відновили освітній процес
дякуючи бо в рокам крові до коли ми
змогли в перший рік чі зрозуміти причини
втрати якості і запровадити новітні
інструменти які б певно чому змінили
нашу освітню боротьби онлайн на освітні
парадигми ми змогли зменшити втрати
якості освіти і саме тому на сьогодні в
будь-якому можливому варіанті ми
пропонуємо принаймні змішане навчання
але з урахуванням перш за все безпекової
ситуації
по нашим по нашим прогнозам по нашим
оцінкам по нашим зрізалам звісно в
різних категоріях навчань наприклад
початковій школі був більшості освітніх
музей рівень не змінився звісно є
предмети більш складні наприклад
математика хімія фізика традиційно які є
більш складними в сприйнятті дітей Там
звісно є і викладачі і експерти
відмічають якість падіння наприклад
знань але при цьому Ми певними
індивідуальними формами Ми вирівнюємо
наприклад організацію окре
на території учня і вчителя по кожному з
окремих предметів наприклад розбірка
покрокових інструкцій для опанування
певних певних матеріалів і завдань
підвищеної складності внутрішньому
моніторингу результатів навчання це все
сьогодні є прописано в рекомендаціях і
ми дуже активно це впроваджуємо а якщо
взяти результати навчання в старшої
школі то там найменше є падіння якості
навчання адже діти також уже свідомо
додатково займаються для складання або
ЗНО або ММД по цих складних предметах і
саме в цьому але традиційно те ж саме
фізика хімія Математика є відмічається
ті певні падіння в якості оскільки
онлайн освіта також ніколи не може стати
аналогом сучасної освіти може лише бути
додатком в засвоєнні і в отриманні тих
залишкових знань Які сьогодні вимагає
компетентності нової української школи
Якщо говорити про матеріальний бік
справи по-перше Чи постраждали від
російських обстрілів якісь ще нові
заклади освіти яких збитків задала атаки
Дронів Які взагалі в якому стані
фінансова частина освітнього процесу Чи
все гаразд можливо чогось не вистачає А
я вам дуже дякую за запитання ну перш за
все ніколи не буває фінансовим плаває
зайвими адже освітні процеси завжди
інновації завжди був вперед інновації
вимагають вкладання певних додаткових
коштів але при цьому Ми чітко розуміємо
що сьогодні війна сьогодні пріоритети
розставлені саме в безпековому
середовищі України в
національній безпеці в захисті країни в
підтримці збройних сил і це це дійсно є
сьогодні пріоритетом адже якщо ми не
Захистимо державу далі про будь-який
проекти гуманітарні освітянські всі інші
взагалі немає про що говорити тому
освітяни ВПО зараз з певним секвестром
бюджету на 22-й рік ми дуже
економно-раціонально ефективно
використовували ті кошти і впорались
навіть воєнний час і не завданнями
інвалідаційними в тому числі завданнями
які ставились перед нами так само ми на
сьогодні плануємо свій бюджет плануємо
бюджетнуємо його на наступний рік і
сподіваюсь що і впевнений що освітня
система витримає будь-які будь-які
виклики цього середовища адже саме
великий виклик це війна і загроза
російської агресії якщо план якщо
сьогодні відповідати на другу частину
нашого запитання стосовно кількості
зруйнованих пошкоджених заходів хочу
нагадати що сьогодні 320-6 закладів
освіти взагалі повністю зруйновано а
пошкоджено 2 337 і Загалом ми маємо
2663 заклади освіти які які мають
пошкодження або руйнування якщо брати
над новіші атаки які відбувалися 10
жовтня 17
то на сьогодні внаслідок атаки броні в
ракетної атаки ми сьогодні маємо 38
закладів освіти
пошкоджених і в тому числі і будівлі
Міністерства освіти і науки яка повністю
непридатна до використання дякую вам
а і пана міністра традиційне вже на
тепер запитання - це про підготовку до
опалювального сезону чи внесли в цей
процес якісь корективи оці терористичні
атаки Росії Якщо можна коротко Дуже
дякую за запитання хочу заспокоїти і
освітян і батьків перш за все до
опалювального сезону Ми готувалися
завжди і за дорученням президента за
дорученням поля до голови уряду ми
завжди готувалися в будь-який рік дуже
завчасно до опалювального сезону
починаючи навіть закінчення Минулого
року ми завжди починали готуватись до
наступного і саме тому сьогодні
в 12 областях ми вже маємо 100%
готовність до полюбного сезону наприклад
такі області як Вінницька Волинська
Житомирська
івано-франківська Київський
Кіровоградська Одеська Полтавська
Рівненська Тернопільська Хмельницької
Чернівецька і всі заклади освіти в цих
областях повністю готові школи готові до
опалювального сезону в 12 інших місцях і
міста Києва садочки на 100% готові 13
областях і міста Києва на жаль найгірша
ситуація в районах де ведуться активні
бойові дії і там неможливо провести
обстеження в тому числі на тимчасового
окупованих територіях якщо взяти погалу
взяв наприклад заклади фахової перевищує
вищої освіти на сьогодні на 78% готові
до опалювального сезону
професійно-технічна освіта на
80-8% готові а заклади загальної
середньої освіти або школи в цілому в
Україні на 92% дошкільна освіта - це
дитячий садочки готові на 92%. і в
цілому готові закладів освіти до
опалювального сезону складає 91%. як
про міністрів Дуже дякую за розмову і як
завжди за вашу роботу я нагадаю що на
зв'язку був Сергій шкарлет міністр
освіти та науки України Дякую вам дякую
Вам слава Україні